this video is brought to you by nano
creators of virtual reality tools for
immersive molecular visualization and
interaction follow the link in the video
description to download nano man explore
molecules yourself
so I mentioned previously that I would
talk about the details of protein
structure later and so here I kind of
want to introduce the levels of protein
structure and there are four levels they
are primary secondary tertiary and
quaternary structure and let's just go
through the basic idea behind each one
and what each one refers to starting
with primary so primary structure refers
specifically to the order or to the
sequence of amino acids that are linked
in the polypeptide chain so it's not
just about which amino acids are there
but the actual order in which they're
connected okay
that's what primary structure refers to
cool and of course there's more details
we'll talk about that stuff in we're
talking about more on each of these in
their own separate videos okay
secondary structure secondary structure
refers to the ordered patterns or 3d
Arrangements on localized regions of the
backbone or the ply peptide chain and
notice that backbone here is capitalized
that's really important because when
people think about secondary structure
they typically think about alpha helix
ease and beta pleated sheets and they're
absolutely right to think that and they
also think about hydrogen bonds again
absolutely right to think that but the
hydrogen bonds specifically are between
the amide hydrogen's and the carbonyl
oxygen atoms and those atoms are the
atoms of the backbone of a polypeptide
chain okay this does not include the
side chains because there are higher
there can be hydrogen bonds between
these side chains or the are groups of
amino acids though that's not described
or referred to by secondary structure
that instead is tertiary structure okay
so tertiary structure refers to the
overall folded 3d structure okay what
does it look like overall that's also
called the quote-unquote native
conformation and almost always when
becomes the tertiary structure the key
thing that I want people to think about
is side chains so interactions between
the side chains of the amino acids
because when a polypeptide folds it's
inevitable that side chains will be
interacting with each other so what what
are the interactions that are there and
what's going to be holding this 3d
structure together and of course there
are hydrogen bond
there's a hydrophobic interactions
there's electrostatic interactions all
of which are non covalent and then
there's the covalent bonds that can
occur between side chains specifically
disulfide bridges between cysteines okay
tertiary structure also refers to the
relationships between secondary
structures so that if there are multiple
alpha helix sees multiple plated pleated
sheets and they're all interacting one
way or another - you know as part of a
full 3d structure that's included in you
know it is referred to and described by
tertiary structure and the involvement
of any prosthetic groups you're talking
about tertiary structure one example of
a hot prosthetic group is heme and a
prosthetic group is any non amino acid
component of a protein so he's got like
a little iron and a bunch of carbons and
nitrogen's and rings and stuff I'll
probably show that at some point when I
talk about hemoglobin but typically when
I think well when people think of
tertiary structure or when I want them
to think about sorcery structure I want
them to think about the interactions
between the side chains okay and last
but not least is the quaternary
structure and quaternary structure
refers to the functional association or
interaction of or between two or more
polypeptide chains or subunits long
story short if you got a protein with
two or more polite peptide chains or
subunits that protein has quaternary
structure if it does not have multiple
sidechain I'm sorry multiple subunits or
multiple polypeptide chains then it does
not have quaternary structure okay
that's kind of the general idea for all
of these talking about more of the
details in the following videos hope the
audio is helpful thank you for watching